hello welcome to the debate on Sky News
I'm Martin Stanford here's our take on
developments brought together from
America the UK and around the world of
the institution FIFA and books and
around the world thank you very much for
your kind attention are we entering a
new era for world football the u.s. city
which is depriving its residents of
fresh water and carries lapse of
concentration forces him to miss vital
talks there's going to be a deep clean
of FIFA's finances a radical overhaul of
his administration and a new president
after set Blatter resigned after almost
20 years in charge so what now for
football's world governing body well as
usual the Democrat commentator Geoffrey
Robinson is in New York and the
conservative commentator Armstrong
Williams is standing by in Washington
Jeffrey what next for world soccer Oh
big big big problems this is from a
journalist this point of view this is
the gift that keeps on giving it's been
what about a week now that since the
story of 10 days since the story is
broken and I must say I've got to say
that the sister company of Sky News The
Wall Street Journal has been brilliant
in its coverage they've been on top of
this from day one inside the hotel when
the arrests were happening and and I
mean it's just been great from the
standpoint of writing a story the thing
is that I was in a meeting last week of
private meeting about financial crime in
which there was an FBI agents from the
same office that began this
investigation three years ago when
Loretta Lynch now the Attorney General
was the US attorney for the Eastern
District of New York now these agents
weren't in on the investigation but you
know the scuttlebutt around the office
and what they said was bladder and
vulchy his French assistant are the
targets and I'm afraid there is just no
escape I'm strong it's surprising in a
sense it's taken so long to get well
we've got to now isn't it
what I'm going to surprise you today
everyone knows that FIFA in the world
cup is corrupt and countries are just as
corrupt weather is Valley move Putin in
Russia whether it's someone and Dubai
any place that's competing for these
games is no different if you wanted to
put a microscope on the Olympics you
could find the same corruption the same
bribery the same schemes no different
than the Chicago White Sox scandal in
the United States no different than the
NCAA shaving basketball points in the
United States so yeah and we understand
that the banking scheme is connected to
New York and that Loretta Lynch was
involved in she has an understanding of
this but is this a way for her to
introduce herself to the world we could
care less about soccer in the United
States we could care less about his
leadership we have no interest in it and
yet America is obsessed with skin does
this tie back and the fact that Russia
got the the world cup and President
Obama his administration has serious for
very issues with Russia they want to
further embarrass him by giving the
impression that there's a possibility it
could be taken away from him I don't
think most Americans care I think
corrupt I mean you can look at many
institutions you can look at our
government and find schemes where people
paid off in campaigns so I'm just trying
to understand why all of a sudden has
the United States decided to take on
FIFA well let's see if we can find out
shall we because one guy who can help us
is with us today let's speak to the
sports lawyer co-founder of change FIFA
campaign David Larkin who joins us from
Washington you want to change David
you've been arguing for it for years
what should be the first bit of change
that should come about well I think you
have to understand that this
organization has scandal after scandal
after scandal this is not a new day
that's a nun new phenomenon and FIFA
this is a very old phenomenon fever the
problem has been that we have in essence
FIFA is little more than a secretive
club of 25 plus or minus two people who
have who operate in secret and have no
accountability to anyone but themselves
that sets up the conditions which we
the over and over and over again that
this out this organization at this level
this very FIFA Executive Committee are
always the people targeted with
allegations of impropriety and who in
fact you commit impropriety it's uh it's
it's largely this one entity that's
responsible for much of the impropriety
that we've seen should the world cup
bids for the next two competitions be
revisited do you think using well I
think it depends on the facts and i
think that the Sunday Times has done a
brilliant job among many other papers of
really raising some serious questions
about how this process was conducted
moreover I think you have to understand
that there exists a report in fact
multiple reports about the allegations
of impropriety levelled at this
organization now they're kind of
self-serving because they were carried
out by P p'zone investigator Michael
Garcia but those invest those reports do
in fact exist but they've been withheld
by FIFA for reasons that frankly I do
not understand worse mr. Garcia this
organization is so discredited the mr.
Garcia who carried out these
investigations resigned and discussed
that because this organization doesn't
take impropriety or corruption seriously
Jeffrey let's bring you back in at this
point these two please do because I have
to I first of all my friend David I have
to take exception with his criticism of
Mike Garcia Mike Garcia is a former US
Attorney that report is not at all
self-serving which is why FIFA
suppressed it and which is why the Swiss
are now using that as the basis for
their investigation but Armstrong you
know last week Armstrong and I were in
total lockstep with everything I'm glad
to see it's not contagious and doesn't
continue to this week because I'm strong
as usual has got it totally wrong I mean
he completely misunderstands what this
is all about bring up the White Sox
scandal which was known as the Black Sox
scandal of 1919 match-fixing and is
nothing to do with that it has nothing
to do with any of that this has to do
basically with the extortion and
shakedown of US companies you've met the
FBI should be involved and you bet the
Attorney General should be concerned
this is not something that Loretta
just cooked up yesterday this has been
going on for three years they've been
gathering evidence now the interesting
thing is that when the scandal broke and
the original six people were arrested
and it's interesting to note that
Interpol has now issued red notices for
six people who are not in Switzerland
and requesting their immediate arrest
but when the scandal broke bladder
immediately defended himself in his own
role in FIFA said he would not withdraw
from the election not postpone the
election for the presidency and
everybody thought well he's going to dig
in his heels we have in the United
States a system called plea-bargaining
which says to some of the people who are
today sitting in jails in Zurich which
is a big come down from the room service
at the bar a lot hotel they're sitting
in jail cells and they're being told by
American prosecutors instead of serving
20 years in jail we know how you can
probably cut that in half and as of that
very morning when they walked into the
bar lock hotel and arrested these people
set bladder had no friends because again
he's the target and they will plea
bargain to get the evidence on him I am
convinced that there are unsealed
indictments in the system right now with
bladder and vulpes in a minute these
guys are in the serious problems because
they shipped down American companies
that's extortion that's an American
crime well let me pick up Jeffrey with
that point to Armstrong hear about and
of course Americans should care about
this if there's wrongdoing been done on
American soil or American companies are
implicated or American citizens have
been cheated out of staging a World Cup
which is one of the accusations that
hangs in the air then sure shouldn't
Americans care Armstrong a huge listen
there's a larger point here there's no
question there should be kind of nation
for a greed and corruption and
exploitation and billing this feat them
where the few benefit but the countries
are just as guilty do you understand
what what it takes to get the Olympics
in your country you know that it's
almost like the mob that you have to go
through you have to pay kiss the King's
ring the kind of shenanigans you must
involve yourself in are you telling me
you're going to totally overhaul the
complete system not just FIFA but the
Olympics and all these other things that
involve us
just two three four five six wrongs make
a right today it's not you're not going
to change it what are you gonna replace
it with more corruption where it's gonna
be here it's gonna be a place with
complete complete lack of understanding
armstrong total lack of understanding is
gotta be replaced with more corruption
that you can owe an authorization it an
organization that is transparent
operates legally and does not currently
up let me jump in and get David let me
get David whodat who knows a bit about
this having having examined the subject
David Larkin do can FIFA be replaced
either by changing its personnel or
let's say fold up like that chicken
organizations start another one can
world football be run cleanly absolutely
you know I see I think what interesting
to me is if you observe international
sport to mr. Williams point certainly it
is there are great troubles in in world
sport but it really all falls back to
some very simple ideas that in
jurisprudence aren't particularly
complicated due process order of law I
mean for example at a client in Brazil
and the Olympic Committee I proffered
that the Olympic Charter okay at the
very same time in India they said the
Olympic Charter is basically like the US
Constitution meaning it is the paramount
legal document for all the world sport
then when we travel to Brazil and we
said okay we're going to stand on that
principle the IOC will quote told an AP
reporter and they said oh by the way
their mere suggestions so well this is
not complicated we need order and logic
to this process the answers can be found
in modern common law jurisprudence where
you have a system of laws you have due
process you have independence in un you
eliminate conflicts of interest the in a
corruption community knows how to fix
this problem all all that needs to
happen is that governments need to say
with respect to gentlemen the private
parties over the adults are here and
it's time to clean this up but the pace
of change David though might take a
while make it not well I think what it
comes down to is that you need people
and governments to
really have an honest relationship with
sport what sport does at the present
moment as it says this for example let's
take the Women's World Cup in Canada as
an example it says so FIFA says dear
Canada we want you to spend millions and
millions if not billions of dollars on
this event that supports our profits and
by the way if you want to have any say
in the way we operate stay out of it
that's a very unfair bargain that sport
and that happens at the IOC and it
helped happens across the board all over
the world so what essentially happens is
that we have a very dishonest
relationship between society and sport
that needs to be addressed where in
society says you know what here's the
bargain if you're going to take and
profit based on us supporting you to the
tune of billions of dollars the least
you can do is be accountable to us and
that's what needs to happen I'm strong
you're agreeing with David 10 race today
that is the only answer and I respect
what he said and just don't look at FIFA
look at all of sports and their
connection to governments and the people
is just corrupt if you're going to
change the culture of corruption which
you can if you have honest brokers and
government and honest brokers in sports
and that is something we don't have now
if you can change that which is going to
take some time then yes is worthwhile
Jeffrey are you optimistic the change
could come about sure I am sure I am but
I mean let this isn't this this
particular case is not about the Olympic
Committee or cycling doping in cycling
or fixing boxing matches or the Black
Sox scandal of 1919 this is about FIFA
in particular a thoroughly corrupt
mafioso kind of organization what
worries me is the fact that bladder says
he's staying on till December I'm hoping
that Swiss prosecutors will be in there
to make sure no records get destroyed
and David Larkin would you think that
actually set Blatter order to step down
a lot sooner than at the end of the year
yeah i mean mr. Ellison has a great
point and that is this you have a
gentleman who has said that he's
resigning but he's not resigning what
you have is you have the least qualified
person in all of the world to reform
FIFA is set bladder based on not
speculation but a track record a long
track record in which scandal after
scandal after scandal he's promised
reform
and he's proven that he is incapable of
doing it and what should alarm everyone
is that this is the gentleman who's now
tasked himself with staying on board to
reform an organization that he is uh
there is factual proof that he's
incapable of doing so the very worst
person in the world to do this is the
person undertaking this task you should
leave immediately we should be very very
mindful of fact that there's a real
possibility that what's really going on
and this is there's precedent for this
is that he's really point he's setting
up the conditions where his coronation
of a successor takes place and we really
don't have change worse we have an
election coming up now this election
will be prot will be proffered a number
of candidates under the banner of change
the problem is is that a number of these
people Michelle Platini and others are
these people who are part of this
institution for a long time or have the
same cultural values I mean these are
the people who thought the guitar world
cup was a great idea we've got to be so
cautious moving forward about who stands
up and offers themselves as agents have
changed because in my opinion anyone
associated with this culture is not an
agent of change we can believe it from
the change FIFA campaign in Washington
David lucky thank you thank you so much
for having me you can catch up with Sky
News debate on apple TV on roku on catch
up and of course you can find us at Sky
News com / us next Detroit which just
two years ago filed the largest
municipal bankruptcy case in US history
has now shut off fresh water supplies to
more than a thousand residents because
they can't pay their bills and it's
going to get worse there are 65,000
people who are at least two months late
with their payments owing the city
almost 50 million dollars well Leo
Heller is the UN Special Rapporteur on
human rights to water and sanitation
he's currently in Brazil mr. hella thank
you for joining us what's your reaction
when you hear that people are having
their water supply is cut off
yes our contact with the problem started
last year and in October last year my
predecessor Catalina Java karoke
together with the Special Rapporteur on
housing visited the city and saw several
problems regarding water cut-offs and we
are very concerned about the problem
because people affected by the cut-offs
are mainly for people without conditions
are paying the high view that the
municipality is now applying to them so
this is an important question when we
look through the human rights
perspective because affordability is one
of the main issues in the human rights
of water and sanitation mr. hey let me
put the point to you that the water
authorities say it's an effective threat
because most people when faced with a
prospect to being cut off or when it
actually happens immediately find the
money and pay the bill yes I think it's
difficult to generalize the situation
what am I feeling is that most of the
disconnections are applied to people
with below the poverty line so this is
not a question of not want to pay but
not have the conditions to pay and this
is a question a very important issue
when we look through the human rights
perspective I'm not I don't agree that
most of the situations are doing not
wanting to be but mostly not have the
conditions to pay let's bring in
Geoffrey Robinson and New York and
Armstrong Williams in Washington
Armstrong you go first on this one this
is draconian action on behalf of the
Water Authority isn't it depending on
your perspective and especially if
you're out started looking at it and you
look at control story to say that the
United States is a violation of human
rights against you could come to that
conclusion this is a situation that also
that is a greatly impact in Baltimore
and it is a fact that the the local
people who work with the this area works
very closely with people who cannot pay
their bills and they help them set up
payment plans and foresees CNN saying
citizens and people who dis able who
really cannot afford they for many years
have worked with them they help them pay
these bills there are always those able
bodies who wants to exploit the system
and take advantage of it they get luck
with everyone else and these are the
people that they really pursue and what
yes and when they do pursue them almost
six of the seven percent of John not
only do they pay their bills within days
but if they can't they work out a
payment where they do pay these bills I
think this is something that has been
overly exaggerated they make world news
as if the United States does not care
about is poor and is in the gent it's
not true and I do think corporations can
explore and take advantage but i think
these corporations work very diligently
to make sure that people pay and if they
cannot pay put them on a payment plan
where they can pay at the best of their
financial abilities see one of the
problems Jeffrey it seems to be unfairly
picking on individuals on residents who
can't pay these things there are
examples of companies who are in debt to
the Water Authority for tens if not
thousands if not millions of dollars and
they get left alone that's right this
story this story is a big story it's not
about the United States in violation of
Human Rights it's about some but some
companies that don't understand and the
City Council's who are in some in some
instances going along with these
companies so I might say that in Detroit
the City Council has objected to the
foreclosures of of the water system to
the ISO 21,000 and that may be the
targeted number 65,000 21,000 it doesn't
matter if there's one child who's not
getting fresh water that's a real sin
now it's happening in Baltimore
apparently it's also happening in st.
Louis this is horrendous in Baltimore I
saw the figure 369 companies in arrears
of 15 million dollars they have not been
threatened with the having their water
shut off it is the poor in the indigent
who are being targeted and this is
absolutely wrong can you imagine the
humiliation of having to get water as
some people do in Detroit from a Detroit
water brigade people carrying buckets to
their home
with fresh water this is horrendous in
the united states of america in the year
2015 that these companies the water
companies should be allowed to enforce
their will in this way there are
subsidies and the council's need to step
up the state's need to step up and the
US government needs a step we can't
allow any child any child at all in this
country to go without this basic human
right leo hella is it technically a
basic human right i would say that both
the levels of the legislation's are
being broken because there are some
resolutions from the General Assembly
and the Human Rights Council about the
human rights safe drinking water and
sanitation that includes affordability
as one of the contents of the human
rights and at the other side the United
States is bound to this international
legislation because United States joint
consensus on some of these resolutions
and this means that the United States
acept the concept of the human rights to
say to be water sanitation so there is
probably a situation of a violation of
the human rights may I say something
please Jeffrey it's not just a human
rights issue it is becoming a public
health issue you can't do this it is
morally and perhaps legally wrong but
more important it is that child who is
being endangered and we do not have the
right to endanger any child's life by
cutting off water it's sinful I mean I'm
so how come these cities are being run
in such a way that they end up in debt
or going bankrupt or nothing else what's
going on liberalism is dead the Great
Society programs is dead trying to do
for people permanently does not work
people need to learn to do for
themselves they need to understand the
importance of an education for their
children personal responsibility this is
what happens when government has failed
it has failed the people it was very
benevolent it meant
well but you throw these people in a
cesspool and it is very similar and
these cities are being led by Democratic
mayor's our Democratic City Council's
people who wins consider themselves as
victims and minorities are in charge and
yet the situation is not better it's
worth going to ask yourself why because
when give them power they become greedy
take care of their own take care of
corporations that don't pay their bills
and forget about the floor it is an
indictment of little liberalism and the
failed leadership that they continue to
put in power Leah had a final thought to
you I bet you wouldn't when you took up
this job as the Special Rapporteur you
wouldn't have thought that you'd be
dealing with American cities I thought
you'd be thinking of places in the south
of the world at the global South in
Africa and Tom weren't you exactly
exactly it's yes we know that there are
several situations or violations in the
developed countries but of course the
worst situations are in poor countries
so its of course are surprised that so
absolutely impressing situation is
taking place in the US what is important
in this case is that the people affected
by the cut-offs are mostly the most
vulnerable people so it's a very
concerning question because these most
vulnerable poor people disabled people
all the elderly people with chronic
diseases can be extremely affected in
their health and their their dignity on
the situation of cut-offs I'm sure that
the United States has full conditions to
remedy this situation and not disconnect
these people and reconnect people who
was disconnected before there are
several mechanisms that can be taken
place for example subsidies social
protection and several other ways not to
allow this
commissions okay we thank you for your
contribution leo hello thank you for
joining us today thank you now the
Secretary of State John Kerry missed a
key conference on Islamic state after he
broke his leg while cycling during a
break from nuclear negotiations with
Iran in Switzerland he was flown back to
Boston aboard a US military c-17
transport plane so should a man of this
stature really be taking personal risks
let's ask our two experts Geoffrey
Robinson in New York and Armstrong
Williams in Washington Geoffrey how are
you in a bike I'm not nearly as good as
John Kerry but then most people are at
John Kerry is a very serious cyclist I
mean he's got the very serious big
professional bike see he rides with
professionals enough one of the one of
the cycling magazines in the states that
noted that if he were to compete in his
age group in America in cycle races you
know like the Tour de France or tort
America but for his age group he'd be
one of America's top cyclists he takes
this very seriously it's an unfortunate
accident one of the things that
Armstrong will say is well it disrupted
the talks no actually it didn't because
the talks take place on the next low
level down so they continue and he's in
touch but the thing that I found most
interesting is that there was a story
that came out because he takes cycling
so seriously he shaves his legs which
may be too much information Armstrong he
is on Jeff Jeffrey's account then a very
serious cyclist he should be doing this
shitty or do you think this was actually
quite a convenient way of getting out to
some more boring talks with Iran it's
really not about cycling you've got to
stay in shape you need a reprieve these
are very intense talks there's a lot at
stake there's a lot of controversy over
it it's truly still a headache for the
president trying to figure out just
exactly where they're gone and so you
know it you have to admire someone who
sets an example of exercise and is
trying to stay in shape and you know
what you can get it right a thousand
times and induces can have once
misshapen it is age I'm sure would have
a greater impact is very much more
difficult from the heel
and I'm sure they wanted him get him out
of that country as soon as possible to a
place that he's comfortable with in his
home state so he could get it taken care
of and get in rehab as soon as possible
so you know I you know you've got to
respect that about him anybody else
would continue to set that example that
you should do everything you can when
you get a break to stay healthy well
okay Armstrong and Jeffrey I'll leave
you to get out your bike ride for
another week we'll see you soon that's
it for this edition of the debate you
can continue watching sky news on apple
TV on roku on catch up and of course on
Sky News calm until next time goodbye